[Music]
what's the decision to announce
Stargate just
finalized welcome to SRE your ccii TV
and movie
[Music]
channel so I had a lovely sleep last
night oh restful and then I woke up this
morning and check my emails as you know
if you've watched a couple my other the
videos I've hav been checking my emails
quite a lot recently because we
genuinely think the Stargate
announcement might be about to happen
and what was the email that got me so
smiley apparently Monday the 23rd of
October this is yesterday at the point
of recording there was a meeting over
Amazon and MGM Jennifer sui head of MGM
and Amazon pictures Mike Hopkins CEO
currently over at Amazon and most
interestingly Chris tinger who is
currently the head of Amazon MGM
pictures distribution met now it's not
100% clear how many of these people met
in person because some of them did join
in sort of electronically so I can't be
100% certain who was there and who was
just there through you know Zoom but
they were in attendance at the meeting
with several other Executives and hired
people apparently in this meeting my
source tells me people were being called
in and out for three or four hours they
were not just discussing Stargate
obviously but what I'm being told is
they were finalizing decisions over
several projects before they go back
into the meetings with the sagaa
basically the actors's Guild of America
to discuss the actors coming back to
work that meeting starts today so the
point of the meeting on Monday was to
get some of these decisions out of the
way so then they could concentrate on
the negotiations with sagaa for the rest
of the week now you're going to ask me
the big question what did they
decide this is the downside of this I
don't know unfortunately my source and I
can't tell you too much about how they
know because obviously it would allow
certain people to identify them but my
source is aware that the meeting
happened they're aware of what the
meeting was in regards to but they can't
actually tell me what was finally
decided because they're not part of that
group or decision or you know it doesn't
go through them so unfortunately right
now we don't know I have dropped an
interesting email across to MGM
personally I have been lucky enough to
actually have some contact officially
through MGM I have asked them if this
meeting did happen and if it did what
was the conclusion and as soon as I get
a response I'm going to let you know but
if this was the finalization if this
genuinely was the managers basically
putting the signature on saying yes go
then what does that mean well I've
spoken to a couple of my other sources
this morning and one who does work in
the industry has said that yes this this
would happen just before an announcement
and it could literally be hours or days
and PR and marketing basically won't
waste time once they've got the all
clear to go marketing and PR basically
would have said this is what we want to
do this is when we want to do it do we
have permission yes rubber St amped boom
gone so whatever was decided on that day
is when we will actually get the
announcement now I've told you that
Thursday this week that'll be October
the 26th is an interesting day the
people over at Slytherin the guys that
are designing the new Stargate
timekeepers game are actually having a
big Stargate celebration that day Amanda
Tapping is going to be present Darren
from gate world is going to be there and
the people that actually designed the
game as well as a couple of people from
the original sg1 production it's going
to be a proper celebration of Stargate
because October the 26 is the
anniversary the 29th anniversary of the
original Stargate movie being released
now wouldn't that also be an interesting
day for them to announce the new
Stargate movie now I'm not saying this
is definitely going to happen I'm not
saying I have any inside information
that it might happen I'm just saying
that's an interesting possibility and it
might be one of the reasons why they
wanted to have the meeting on Monday
before or they have basically going into
the negotiations Etc which may drag on
for another week or two so it is
possible How
likely I think we've learned by now not
to cter chickens when it comes to the
Stargate announcement it will happen it
will happen at some point but just
because it makes sense to us to do it on
Thursday because that's the anniversary
of the original Stargate movie coming
out doesn't mean that's when they'll
actually do it all I can tell you is I
honestly believe and again this is only
my opinion but I honestly believe
Slytherin are waiting to release the
Stargate timekeepers game because they
need to know what Amazon are doing with
the movie and at the end of the day they
know that their sales will Skyrocket if
they release this game just after
basically Amazon MGM announc that
they're doing a stargame movie if they
release before that their sales will not
be as good so one of the reasons why
we're waiting for the game is because
Slytherin are waiting for Amazon but
Slytherin say that game will be out this
Autumn so we may only be days away but
get into the comments and tell me what
you think is this an interesting piece
of news are you
intrigued or do you think this is just
one more step towards well really this
is a nothing a news because we don't
really know what they said but we know
that the conversations are happening we
know Stargate was on the agenda with
Robocop and a few other things as well
as well so we're working in the right
direction do you actually think though
that Thursday is a very likely
possibility for the announcement out of
seven Chevrons how many would you give
it I'm going four just because I've
learned to not have too much confidence
but how many Chevrons would you give it
get into the comments and tell me if you
are new to the Channel please like
subscribe hit that Bell notification it
really helps us out and you'll never
miss any of our new videos also you can
go to patreon.com / Sid trer you get to
see most of our new videos first and for
a small contribution each month you get
to see them without the adverts and you
even get a free gift after three months
can't say further than that also go to
s.o. which is our dedicated website
where we do articles based on most of
our videos and we try to add a little
bit more information for you to digest
go check it out as always please stay
safe and keep an eye on Sidra on
Thursday you never know see you
guys
[Music]